よろしくお願いします
今日はあのページの番目からでしたかね
番目終わりました あのサンヨージェナというあの仏教の言葉なんですね
サンヨージェナ サンヨージェナっていうのは
まあいろいろものを一緒にまとめるという意味なんですね
いわゆるミックスする意味というなんです
ミックスマッシュよ まあ何か例えば料理の場合は何かスープを作るんだと
それでまあ 水にいろんなものを入れてミックスさせまして
それからいろんな工程をして
それでスープっていうものは出来上がっちゃうんですね
そういう働きなんです
サンヨージェナっていうのは
英語の単語を見ると 仏教の立場から言うと
やっぱり全てのものはもう現象という立場をとっているし
で 無常であって変化していくんですね
変化していくんだけど
生命には 人間には 物事はそういうふうに変化しているものというふうに見えないんですね
何か一つの個体として我々に感じたりするんです
で 物事は個体としてなければ
私たちには見えないし
聞こえないし 味わうこともできないし
触れることもできないし
ですから 見えたという認識
味わったという認識っていうのは
まあ物事を個体として受け取って出てくる認識なんですね
ですから この認識自体を我々は個体化しているんですね
いろんな認識 たくさんまとめた
まとめてから知ったんだと思います
花を見て これはバラの花だと認識すると
それはたくさん認識を得たことをまとめて新しい判断を作って
バラの花と呼ぶんですね
本当はバラの花というものは実体ではなくて
それは頭の中で作る幻覚であって
見たのは違うものなんですね
見たという認識というのは全く違うものなんです
で そういうふうに認識の中でいろいろまあまとめる働きがあります
いろんな情報を結びつく働きがあります
例えば人が立って喋っているとする
それで私たちは何のことなく
あの人は喋っていると認識するんですね
でも心の中でそんな一発で人は喋っているということは認識できません
エネルギーは違いますからね
見えるという働きと聞こえるという働きは全く別々な働きの流れなんです
で 一緒にならないんです
それでも私たちにとっては
その人は喋っているとという認識が生まれてしまっちゃうんです
で そういう風に全部一か所にまとめてしまう
その物事を瞬間瞬間 また別に関係なく
他のものと関係なく 別々ないろんなエネルギーをまとめて一つの働きだと認識させる
その働きの勉強なんですね
サンヨージェナっていうのは
違う例で言えば 例えば車があるんだという
でも車があるんだといっても
車というものは全く違う働きする他の部品たくさんまとめたところで
車というものは出来上がっちゃうんですね
そこで車の働きは車の部品一つもやってないんです
そのその部品に聞けば
あなたはどんな仕事をしていますか？というと
全く別な仕事をしているだけなんです
で だから車の本当の働きは誰がやるかというと
それまた誰もやってるわけじゃないんですね
じゃあエンジンですかと言ったって
エンジンはただどこにも動かないんですね
エンジンには全然動く能力はないんです
回す能力はあるんだけど
動かないんです エンジンを車から外してもらって
それをスタートしたところで
エンジンは回せますけど
自分で でも一センチも動かないんです
でも車といえば動く 距離を動く機械なんですね
そうすると車輪かというと
車輪には何の力もないんです
車輪の仕事というのは
ただそれまた回るだけで
一つ一つネジの仕事はなんだけど
ネジの仕事はもうそんなに関係ないんですね
何か二つの三つのものを一つに離れないようにしてあげる
そこで私たちには車という概念が生まれてくるんですね
部品 部品の別々の働きは分からなくなっちゃうんですね
で まあそういうような感じで我々の認識が働いているんだから
人間は輪廻に執着して
輪廻という幻覚に執着して
私がいるという幻覚に執着して
苦しみをずっと繰り返しているんだ
で といっても なぜこの幻覚が生まれるかということをまた勉強しなくちゃいけない
そういうわけで この結ぶ働き
つなげる働きも別に 勉強しなくちゃいけないんです
例えば車の場合は なぜ車が成り立つかというと
車については煩悩は三業じゃないはないんだけど
強引に例えですから じゃあ車にとって三業じゃないって何ですか？と言えば
それは車とまるっきり関係ない人間の工学的な能力なんですね
だから そういう車の工学を知っている人に部品をあげたら
綺麗にまとめるんですね
一箇所に まとめたところで車になってしまっちゃうんですね
車の部品全部揃って子供にあげたら
決して車っていうのは出てこないんです
そこで全く別な働きする部品が車にするためには
やっぱり工学知識ある工学知識っていうものは必要なんですね
それで工学知識あるんだから
そこに車があるんじゃないかという私たち
たちにこの新しい働きが出ていることです
そこで部品には全然興味ない人は車にはすごい興味あるんですね
部品に対して何の欲望も何もないんです
役に立たないんだと 面倒くさいんだと思う人は
車にする人はすごい執着を持ってるんです
そういうことで だからその執着を作った犯人は誰かというと
やっぱりその光学認識なんですね
そこでその我々の体の中で
存在の中で そういう光学認識って何ですかっていうことなんですね
産業でなくて 今まとめるという意味で
よく一緒にまとめる 合わせる
結びつく それはその名前でいうと種類があるんですね
それはカーマラーガ ルーパラガ
アルーパラガ パティガ
マナ シーラ バタ パラマサ
ビチキッチャー ウッダッチャ
アヴィッジャ そういうのはいろんなところで説明しましたから
今日はずっと説明する必要はないと思いますけど
パティガ マナ 順番に この 10種類なんですね
この 10種類も全部心の働きなんですね
あるいは心に生まれる心所なんです
カーマ ラーガ ルーパラガ
アルーパラガ パティガ
マナ ディッティ シーラ
バタ パラマサ ヴィチキッチャー
ウッダッチャ アヴィッジャ
この順番 なんでこの順番に書いたかちょっとわかりません
普通はその順番じゃないんだけど
で そういう風に今まで我々は 52種類の心所勉強しましたから
その 52種類の心所から違うことを言っているわけじゃないんです
その中に入っているものなんですけど
で いろいろ働きをその場その場でするんです
で このカーマ ラーガ ルーパラガ
アルーパラガというものはラーガですから欲なんですね
結局ローバという心所で言ってる欲なんです
欲もいろいろありまして
で カーマっていうのは
この眼耳鼻舌身という体
体に触れる情報にカーマというんですね
目に触れる情報にカーマというし
耳に触れるものに 音にもカーマというし
舌に触れる味にもカーマというし
鼻に触れる香りにもカーマというし
体に触れる硬さと熱さにもカーマというんです
ですから それはカーマと言われる情報ですね
五種類の物質的なエネルギーなんですね
六種類ありますけど 一応五種類の物質的なエネルギー
その五つは似てないんです
全く違うエネルギーなんですね
見えるものと聞こえるものは全く違うと
と分かりますからね 簡単に
味と香りが全く別な働きなんですね
同じですよというならば
舌でも香りを感じるはずでしょうし
同じですよというのは
例えば あの舌で我々は硬さとか感じますけどね
味も感じる 体の硬さ感じますけど
体に何か食べ物を体に塗ってみても
美味しいかどんな味するかっていうことは何もわからない
で ですから この働きは別々
その別々な働きは 我々は心で同じものだと
その原因の一つはこのカーマに対する色声香味触に対するラーガ
欲なんですね で 見えたもの
聞こえたものを好きになってしまっちゃったら
囚われてしまったら その働きによって一つに心の中でまとめてしまう
で こちらで特別にアビダンマの意味は
仏教の意味は なぜ人が死んでも
生身が死んでも また再びそのエネルギー塊としてどこかで現れてしまうんですね
で なかなか消えないんです
いわゆる輪廻転生してしまうんですね
解脱はしないんです 幻覚の中にいるんです
ずっと幻覚の中にいて苦しんでいる理由は
この眼耳鼻舌身に触れる色声香味触という五つの物質的なエネルギーに対して
すごく欲が生まれるんですね
そこで見たらまた見たいと
聞いたらまた聞きたいと
味わったらもう一度味わいたいと欲が生まれてくる
欲が生まれてくるのも
やっぱり見たもの 聞いたもの
味わったものは 永久的に一回限りだよということがわからないんですね
二度と同じものを見られるはずがないし
二度と同じものを聞こえるはずがないんです
それなのに私たちはまた見たい
また聞きたいと あの人ともう一度会いたいと
と思ったりする それで新しい続きたいというエネルギーが生まれるんですね
そういうわけで この欲
物質に対する欲が生まれてきます
物質といっても知らない物質に対しては知りませんだからね
人間知ってる物質っていうのは色声香味触それだけ
こんな巨大な大胆な物質のことを知ってるわけじゃないんです
実際に知っているのは
その色声香味 それから触という見えるもの
聞こえるものとかね その五つのエネルギーしか知りません
それなのに頭でまた妄想して
いろんなことを知ってるんだと
それまた錯覚なんですね
だから人が知ってるんだと
体に五根に関係ないものも知ってるんだと偉そうに言ってることを明確に分析してみると
結局聞いたもの見たものをまたさらに編んで
さらに現象化したことなんですね
例えば宇宙の果てにある星が見えたと
発見しましたと 写真出してくれる
その場合も なんとかして目で見えるようにして
目で見えたものについていろいろ計算して
頭で何かを結論出すだけなんですね
ですから そちらにもあるのも見えたかという情報だけなんです
そういうことを強調するのはなぜかというと
このお釈迦様の時代でこのヴェーダ聖典なんかね
梵天の神様がね で アッタカ・ヴァーマカ・ヴァーマデワ・ヴェッサーミッキャ・パーラーヤナ・バフットという八人の仙人たちにヴェーダを教えたんだと
神様がそういうふうに言っていて
だから真実だよ でお釈迦様いうのは
それは聞こえたということですよ
で 音ですと 音というものは無常であって
変化している物質の流れであって
それから聞いたものを判断するのは人間ではないかと
そこで我々はそれに聞いているものは正しく判断するかしないかと
そこはまた問題ですと
そこでまた聞いたものも
そのその人が自分なりに解釈したり判断したりするんだから
結局正しいものは伝わりませんと
たとえ神の音が八人に聞こえていたっても
八人が八種類の聴覚が生まれて
八種類の思考方法思考を働かせて
八種類の考え方を出してしまっちゃうんですね
だから本当に神が言ったことを伝わったかというと
そうかもしれませんし
そうでないかもしれませんという二つの立場が出てくるんですね
ですから お釈迦様はいうのは
まあその言葉はそうかもしれませんし
あるいはそうでないかもしれませんし
ですから真実かないかっていう場合は五分五分なんですね
五分五分なんです で その場合も
この仙人 八人の仙人たちが正直者だと仮定したならば
そこら辺お釈迦様もやっぱりその八人が嘘を言ってないんだという立場で
正直者やと 自分が正直者で聞こえたことを言っているだけ
それなの それでも いくら正直者であろうとも
やっぱり真実かないかということは五分五分です
だからしっかりしていないんだと
そういう神の言葉っていうのは
まあそのまま信じるっていうことはまあ不可能かと
本当かもしれません あるいは嘘かもしれません
その二つがあるんです
次に出てくる問題は じゃあ本当だとするならば
あるいはどうやって確かめるかというと
まあその言ってる言葉を明確に見ることなんですね
言っていることは明確に見ると
まあそういう大胆な知恵が見つからないんですね
必ず矛盾が入っているんですね
そういうわけで この神の言葉というものはね
聖書 どんな聖書であろうとヴェーダ聖典であろうか
考えてみると ちょっと読んでみると
人間の存在の問題については答えてない
ただ なんとかあなた方はこうしなさいとそう言ってるだけ
なんでそうしなくちゃいけないんですかということには答えてないんですね
なんで神が創ったかということにも答えてないんですね
そういうことで この 眼耳鼻舌身から入る情報について
人間が欲を作ったりする
欲を作ったりしたら そこで束縛が生まれて
ずっと物事をまとめてまとめて考えるようになって
無明になるんだと で  2番目はルーパラーガなんですけど
これは経典の解釈 注釈書の解釈でいろいろ違ってあって
まあルーパラーガっていうのは
注釈書やら経典の解釈っていうのは
この色界という梵天に生まれたがるということなんですね
出ガストの立場から見れば
まあそれはその解釈は合ってるんですね
で なぜかというと 例えば人が人間ではもう諦め
飽きちゃって 生まれ変わりたくないと
人間として生命生きることは大変苦しいんだと思う可能性はいくらでもあります
で 鋭い人 感覚鋭い人 あまり欲が少ない人
眼耳鼻舌身に囚われない人々がいますからね
まあ飽きちゃったと 何の意味もないんだと
思っても じゃあ眼耳鼻舌身に頼らない生命であるならばいいんじゃないかというふうに思う可能性があるんですね
ですから 自分の生命の次元変えようと
こんな人間の次元ではなくて
人間が目で見て生きれるんだと
鼻で嗅いで生きてるんだと
これはもうやりきれないんだと
何の意味もないんだと
不満だけですよと 見てももう満足できない
聞いても満足できない
嗅いでもいくら嗅いでも満足できない
不満 苦しみが生まれてくると
それだったら この見える聞こえるものに依存しない次元
存在の次元があれば そこら辺いいんじゃないかなと思うかもしれませんね
そちらのもう見えるのは欲なんですね
今の存在は 今の生き方は良くないと
もっと高いレベルの生き方はいかがでしょうか？という感じですから
やっぱり欲が働いてるんですね
その欲なんですね ルーパラーガっていうのは
高い次元の生き方はいいんじゃないか
ですから 色界に対する欲だと
色界に対する欲があったら
また輪廻は終わらないんですね
高次元の天国にも行かないで
天国も脱出させて色界に行くんだと
そのためにはすごく厳しく瞑想しなくちゃいけないし
そうしても その人は梵天に生まれ変わりますからね
欲が消えてないと そういうわけで
高次元の生命 高次元になっても
高次元的なところに生まれ変わっても
それまた輪廻の中だよと
また煩悩があるんだということで
ルーパラガということを言ってるんですね
そこでアルーパラガっていうのは
アルーパっていうのはルーパでない色でないという意味で無色と書くんですね
無色界 で 無色界っていうのは心だけの世界なんですね
そこで梵天に生まれても
眼耳鼻舌体に頼らないんだけど
そこにまた体があって
体に頼って生きてるんですね
やっぱり味わったり食べたりはしない次元なんですね
それでも体を維持しなくちゃいけないんだから
心のエネルギーで維持しているんですね
それで心のエネルギーがちょっと弱くなったら
その梵天が死んでしまっちゃうんですね
そこで そこをわかった人々はもっとより高次元でいこうではないかと
完全に物質的なものに依存しない
この宇宙の中にどのように探しても見つからない
この宇宙とは全く関係ない
物質と関係ないんだから
次元へ行っちゃえば まあそれでいいんじゃないかなと
だから色界の梵天っていうのは物質的な存在だから
この宇宙のどこかにいるんです
で 我々の科学的な五根では見つからないんですけどね
五根で見つからないんだから
科学の世界では見つからないんですね
だから五根で知ってる物質ではないんです
例えば地水火風っていうのは
どう頑張っても五根で見つかることは不可能なんですね
それは瞑想で体験するものなんですね
エネルギーとして それを体験するためには
現象的な物事を体験することはちょっと乗り越えなくちゃいけないし
まあですからこの科学で見つからないんだけど
人間には見えないんだけど
まあ結局は物質的なエネルギーだから
宇宙にどこか宇宙の中にどこかにいる存在なんですね
それでやっぱり物質的な存在だから
それまた良くないんだと思った人は
物質を否定して心のみ心だけ
わずかな物質にも頼ってはいけませんと
それはいけない 頼らないで心だけの次元になったら
まあ宇宙とは関係ないんだから
そういうところに行こうではないかと思って
厳しい修行して まるっきり物質に頼らない心を作るんですね
私たちには目でしかものを見えないんですね
時々錯覚を起こしちゃうんですね
目がなくても見える場合もありますね
あれは何ですかというと
あれはやっぱり脳の中で化学反応を起こしちゃうでしょ
それで見えるんです ですから
やっぱり物質から体を刺激しなきゃ
脳っていうのは体ですからね
見えるということは生まれません
ですから この物質に依存しない心を作るということは
もう大変な修行の結果なんですね
そういう修行の結果として
物質と関係ない次元に生まれ変わるんだと決めると
もしそこで生まれ変わったら
この宇宙のどんな人にも
そういう人とはコンタクトが取れなくなっちゃうんです
でもそちらにいたいと
という欲があるんだから
それまた輪廻の中だと
というのは 修行の目的
解脱の目的から定義すると
そういうふうになるんですね
その三つは欲なんです
それから一般的にごく普通な解釈もできるんです
その三つに カーマラーガっていうのは正真正銘のことで
認識を起こしてくれる刺激なんですね
認識を起こしてくれる刺激に対する執着
色声香味触に対する執着はカーマラーガです
より明確に言えば 物質に対するあるいは地水火風に対する執着はルーパラーガ
ルーパに対する執着ですから
その場合は見えるんだから好きですよということではなくて
物質だから実体があるんだから
まあそれはいいんじゃないかなと思ってしまっちゃうんですね
それから三番目のアルーパラーガっていうのは
心に対する執着 私はここで考えたり喋ったりしているんだから
その心 私ではないかと
認識の働きが私ではないかと思って
そこでアイデンティティを作る
で その瞑想中ではよくわかると思いますけど
なんかずっと自分の心は自分だと思うことは
ずっとまあ追っかけてくるんですね
いくら物事変化することはあっても
自分の心は瞬間瞬間変わることは体験しても
まあそれは私だと その中に何か大事な私がいるんじゃないかと
と思っちゃうんです それもアルーパラーガなんですね
アルーパといえば心だと解釈すると
そういう風にこの梵天の次元を使わなくても
梵天やらそういう色界・無色界という高次元の概念を使わなくても
この三業寺のその三つの説明はできるんです
なぜそういうふうに説明したかというと
じゃあこんな梵天とか信じてない人々にとっては
食べて遊んで生きていればそれだけで十分じゃないかと思っている人々にとっては
カーマーラーガがあるんだけど
ルーパラーガ・アルーパラーガがないんではないかなと
と誤解する可能性あります
でも全部あるんです 食べて遊んで楽しんでいればいいんじゃないかなという人が
やっぱり物質に対するすごい執着あるし
それからこの感覚に対するすごい執着を持ってるし
ですから その人にもカーマーラーガもルーパラーガもアルーパラーガも働いてるんです
どんな生命にも働いているんです
そこで四番目はパティガ
パティガというのは 当たるというかね
逆らうという ぶつかるという意味なんですね
逆らってみようではないか
それは一般的に生まれるのは
例えばものを見たら 見えたら見たくないんだと
そのそれは そこパティギャというエネルギーなんですね
見たくないということも束縛なんですね
聞きたくはないということも
やっぱりすごい束縛であって
エネルギーなんですね
これわからないかもしれませんだけど
こういう例でわかるんです
私たちにはすごい嫌いな人がいるんだと
なぜその人を嫌いかというと
その人に対する何か関係あるんですね
関係がなければ もう嫌いか嫌いじゃないか
そのそれももう関係ないんだから
だから誰かが好きですよ
だから分かります その人のことを好きだから
もうなかなか束縛されちゃって
まあ囚われているんだと
という人にとって じゃあ嫌いな人がその人が嫌いになったら
それで囚われ消えますかというと消えません
ですから 誰かが嫌いということも
その人に対しては関わりがあるということなんですね
それで心は自由になれない
その人に対し そのものに対して嫌いな思いを引きずらなくちゃいけないんですね
それによって体が心が行動を起こしちゃうんですね
嫌いな人から離れようと
違うものを探すようと
というふうに新しいエネルギーが生まれてくるんですね
ですから パティギャという
これ怒りですけど 訳する場合は怒りなんですけど
それはこの逆らうエネルギーなんですね
そこでパティギャというものも我々またたくさんありますけど
アビダンマでは書いてないんです
逆らえないだけでそこで終わってるんです
で 欲にたくさんありますから
カーマ ラーガとあるんだから
論理的に考えちゃうとカーマ・パティギャもあるはずなんです
ルーパ・パティギャもあるはずなんです
アルーパ・パティギャもあるはずなんですね
そういうふうに まあ論理的に言っちゃえば 3つあるはずなんですけど
あんまり言ってないね
パティギャは 1つでまとめている
逆らうことは ですから
まあわかりやすく言えば
原因に必至に入っちゃう色
声 香 味 触に対して逆らうことはあるし
物質は良くないとそれに逆らう人はいるかもしれませんし
問題は心のエネルギーではないかと
心自体が嫌だよと 私の心はすごく嫌ですよ
というふうに それに対して逆らうこともあるし
結局は欲がなければ逆らえないんですね
ですから 同じ働きなんですね
で 好きという概念がなければ嫌いという概念は成り立たないんですね
だからなんで物事を好きかというと
これ物事はあると思ってるんだからなんですね
物事はあると思った自体が間違ってるんですね
なぜ間違ってるかというと
智慧がないだからなんですね
智慧がある人にとっては物事はないと
瞬間しか現象は生まれませんと
二度と同じ現象は生まれませんと
自分の子供だと思ったら
まあ数弱生まれますけど
自分の子供っていうのはただの言葉であって
概念であって 二度と会えないんですね
一回やったらそれっきり
次に会うのは違う人が違う人に会うんです
そこでまた妄想が働いて
子供だと その違う人を思っちゃうんですね
また会う時も違う人は違う人に会うんだけど
そこでまた子供に会ったと概念作る
その概念ずっとまた固めたら
これは私の子供ですよと思ったところで
まあずっと生まれた時から死ぬまで自分の子供という錯覚が生まれて
そこに執着が大変苦しみ大変生まれてくるんですね
そこで離れなくなる